that's how it works
Ami's with us in nashville hi Amy
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you my husband and I just need some help
trying to figure out if we should move
or stay in our current home where we
live sometimes it takes my husband an
hour and a half to get to work so we're
contemplating with on whether or not to
move closer to his work but the problem
is the reason that we're hesitant is we
just paid off the MIP on our current
home that we purchased about 10 years
ago so we were just trying to figure out
if it would be smart for us to stay
where we are since we just got that paid
off and continue to make payments and
eventually pay this current house off or
would it be smarter to move closer to
his work less wear and tear and gas with
a vehicle she's your home and your home
is where in Nashville this in
Murfreesboro about 45 minutes outside of
Nashville well I live in Nashville I
live in Franklin so I'm no emeritus okay
so and he works where in Nashville yes
downtown Nashville right by the airport
okay and that takes him an hour I guess
it does yeah traffic mhm I said I want a
half sometimes in the traffic those guys
there's a wreck I can take an hour and a
half yeah that's that's not the normal
day though but anyway still no it's
still a long way okay of course the
closer you move that direction depending
on where you are in Murfreesboro your
prices may go up mhm - okay yeah
depending on the particular area that
you're and you there are some places you
could get there though I mean you could
get to the Hermitage area and probably
not see a substantial price difference
and then depending on where you are in
Murfreesboro
but anyway right on the southern here's
the thing we own a home because it's a
nice investment and goes up in value and
we want to be financially smart with it
which is why you're asking this question
we also own a home because it's where we
live
and if I were spending an hour to an
hour and a half each way on the road
every day that house would have already
been sold before you even made this
phone call my commute is seven minutes
now if you live in Los Angeles you may
have an hour-and-a-half commute but even
though Nashville traffic has lost its
ever-loving mind but aside from that an
hour-and-a-half commute in the Nashville
area is unreasonable that's too much of
your life gone in a car seat you know I
just mean I want him to spend more that
time with you and kids if he's got kids
and just having my life
I mean his level his energy level well
his stress level will go down his energy
level will go up you can give him his
life back by moving an hour closer and
be twenty minutes or ten minutes or
something like that away assuming his
job is stable I'm moving tomorrow yeah
he works for the state so it's pretty
secure okay yeah yeah I'm moving
tomorrow I mean it says you can figure
this out I mean I'm being I'm
exaggerating but you see what I'm saying
you're just going guy you're gonna get
your man back that sounds good to me you
lost him to traffic you know you can
find another house I mean it may not be
the exact perfect deal and don't use
this as an excuse to overspend on the
house no we definitely don't want to be
a house for ya
now think about a lateral move is what
I'm thinking about a lateral move is a
no-brainer a slight move up it could be
a no-brainer depending on the rest of
your financial you know for your
finances but just quality of life when
you don't have to I'm done man I'm
moving if I'm you and I know the real
estate market well enough to know that
you depending again depending on where
you are murmur fish pros a hot market
and some of those neighborhoods are much
pricier than some of the neighborhoods
around the airport in Nashville and so
then you can look at Donaldson and
Hermitage and that kind of stuff and he
could get his life back
so I'm gone thanks for the call